our main story tonight concerns drugs
they're something that we've often been
told to avoid through psas like this
[Music]
when they say come home
[Music]
cool
i mean everyone knows the hottest spot
to snort coke is a bench on a
residential street in broad daylight
these days you can't even hang out on
your split level porch in your poodle
skirt without seeing those pesky teens
blowing that snow like it's jackson hole
but despite those very compelling
arguments millions upon millions of
americans still use illicit drugs and it
is easy to see why drugs can be a lot of
fun some in fact can be so much fun they
end up ruining your [ __ ] life because
the truth is that grease fever dream
isn't entirely wrong to imply that
engaging with the illicit drug supply
can be dangerous this past decade has
shown a substantial rise in overdose
deaths leading to alarming statistics
like this
the cdc estimates more than 100 000
americans die from drug overdoses over a
12-month period ending this april a
record that's nearly three times the
number of deaths from traffic accidents
last year and more than twice the number
of gun deaths
wow that is staggering and quick side
note here it is depressingly american to
be shocked that something could cause
more deaths than guns we are the only
country that would look at that and say
it's hard to believe that drug overdoses
are killing more people than one of
those natural causes of death highly
preventable loss of life by loosely
regulated weapons
the fact is street drugs are an absolute
mess right now as they've become so
contaminated one yale researchers said
the whole supply is just so absolutely
[ __ ] at this point and the rise in
overdose deaths has been driven by the
presence of one drug in particular and
that is fentanyl a synthetic opioid
often used for prescriptively for things
like surgeries or cancer pain but
outside of medical settings illegally
manufactured fentanyl has become a huge
problem because it and other synthetic
opioids were involved in nearly
two-thirds of all overdose deaths during
the past year and while it is true that
fentanyl is incredibly potent the bigger
problem is actually that there is a
dangerous lack of consistency in the way
it's currently distributed within the
street drug supply so you can either
know that you're taking it on its own or
in something like heroin but not know
how potent what you're taking is or
you may not know that you're taking it
at all
what we're seeing is that this opioid is
being found in a contaminated pill
supply in the whole united states
they're using pill presses that look
like pills for pharmaceuticals that are
currently marketed one day i admitted
three people into the clinic all three
of them said they were taking oxycodone
none of those three people had any
oxycodone tested in their urine that we
tested that day it was all fentanyl
well that's not great is it the only
time you should be surprised by what is
in your urine is when you forgot you ate
asparagus earlier that day or worst case
scenario the shrunk down magic school
bus comes out after a biology lesson
gone horribly wrong
so if the current drug supply is this
tainted and this dangerous we thought
tonight it'd be worth talking about the
overdoses that it can cause and the
things that we should and really
shouldn't be doing to prevent them and
let's start by acknowledging some past
mistakes because for decades we've been
fighting a war on drugs that was often
fueled by fear and misinformation
directly leading to bad policy in the
1980s for instance the risks associated
with crack cocaine use which were very
real got cartoonishly inflated into
fear-mongering headlines about a
generation of crack babies with stories
like crack babies turn five and school's
brace which was obviously shitty and
racist at the time but has also since
been completely debunked but that
hysteria led to policies like mandatory
minimums that fueled mass incarceration
and laws that criminalized everything
surrounding drug use from paraphernalia
to even locations where drugs were used
and unfortunately we're seeing a similar
panic today brewing around fentanyl
which again is dangerous if ingested or
injected but to hear law enforcement
tell it it's also dangerous to be
anywhere near it take this video from
the san diego county sheriff's
department and before i show it to you
just know the officer involved here is
completely fine for reasons i'll get to
in a minute
my trainee was exposed
to fentanyl
and nearly died he found a white
substance that he suspected was
drugs it takes a positive performance
that's no joke it was super dangerous
couple seconds later he took some steps
back and he collapsed
again don't worry that officer is
completely fine and there should have
been a few immediate red flags there not
only did the department voluntarily
release that body cam footage they also
went to the trouble of scoring it with
music that can only be described as
funeral home slideshow
but the idea that that officer could
have been passively exposed to fentanyl
and then overdosed is completely absurd
experts say it is technically impossible
to touch fentanyl powder and feel any
effects from it let alone overdose and
you would have to be in some sort of
wind tunnel with massive amounts of
fentanyl to accidentally inhale enough
to od and by the way a wind tunnel full
of fentanyl is quite the phrase there if
you just add ant-roving gangs you've
pretty much got how a racist uncle
describes chicago after watching too
much fox news and the thing is it's by
no means just san diego multiple police
departments have put out similar claims
of odin through accidental skill skin
contact or inhalation which again is
basically impossible what those officers
were much more likely experiencing were
panic attacks which makes sense in a way
because they'd just been exposed to
something they'd repeatedly heard is
deadly to be anywhere near this has now
become such a trope it was a plot point
on blue bloods where donnie wahlberg's
partner briefly picks up a tray with
fentanyl on it and then this happens
any idea what she came in contact with
herb says she got fentanyl on her hands
what the hell's happening here she was
fine one second the next minute she's
not breathing fentanyl is a synthetic
opioid 50 to 100 times stronger than
morphine the slightest exposure can
trigger an overdose yeah that is
complete horseshit
not that you'd expect any more nuance
from a show that's basically adult paw
patrol
but
but the point is it is deeply
irresponsible of police to keep
perpetuating a medical impossibility and
for media outlets to keep amplifying it
for a start it might make people afraid
to help someone they see experiencing an
overdose why risk giving someone cpr if
they might be covered in powdered death
and also when you treat a drug like a
bio weapon you justify a punitive
militarized response to it a couple
years back an ohio man received
additional prison time for assault on a
police officer after officers searched
his car for drugs and found powder that
later tested positive for fentanyl that
exposure to fentanyl alone constituted
the assault and look if fentanyl really
were smallpox in a bottle maybe it'd
make sense for total eradication to be
our goal but it isn't so it frankly
makes much more sense to focus on how to
protect those genuinely at risk of
overdosing on it and that is the people
taking it which is to say that the rest
of this piece is actually going to be
about harm reduction essentially harm
reduction accepts the reality that
people will use illegal drugs and that
some either can't or don't want to stop
so rather than arrest them we might be
better off trying to mitigate the damage
done it's a concept that you might
already be familiar with through things
like syringe services programs which
give people clean needles and are proven
to massively help drive down the spread
of disease and right now if you
genuinely want to reduce the number of
overdoses there are some important
tactics that we could encourage first
there is drug checking the simple act of
testing drugs to find out what is in
them this can be done through things
like fentanyl testing strips or reagent
test kits these are very valuable tools
to keep people safe and yet thanks to
those drug war era laws on paraphernalia
that i just mentioned earlier they're
technically illegal in all of these
states making a liability to carry them
which is just complete madness now
thankfully some states have written
carve-outs for specific methods like
fentanyl testing strips and others are
choosing not to enforce their stupid
laws criminalizing them the problem is
though police officers may not be aware
or indeed care about those carve outs
and are still very much arresting people
or using the presence of testing
equipment as probable cause for further
searches all of this means people are
still getting locked up because they
were carrying a life-saving tool which
is ridiculous because if any life-saving
tool should be criminalized it obviously
should not be drug checking equipment it
should be the heimlich maneuver i'm
sorry but let's get this very clear here
if you see me choking that is frankly
none of your business
if i die let me die doing my favorite
thing in the world not being surprised
hugged by a stranger
do not touch me
under any circumstances
then there is the harm reduction method
that you're probably already aware of
and that is naloxone also known by the
brand name narcan naloxone as this woman
who works in harm reduction explains can
quickly reverse an opioid overdose so
pretend like this this here this is the
fentanyl coming in your system right so
when you shoot some up with narcan it's
like a wall goes up and so the fentanyl
hits the wall it can't keep on going the
more narcan you put to the system the
bigger that wall gets so what you're
saying is is it's actually quite easy to
reverse an overdose yes it is
right it's incredibly effective naloxone
has got to be in the hall of fame for
erasing mistakes right up there with the
pencil eraser the control z key and
starring in daddy's home too
what a fun family what a cranky dad i
wonder if there are any fun pranks or
voicemails on the set i bet there were
the point is though naloxone is a
[ __ ] miracle which is why it is so
frustrating that the fda currently has
it under prescription only status
something even the ama has said should
be changed and while every state has
adopted some kind of work around meaning
an individual can theoretically get it
without seeing a doctor first it can be
very difficult and for community groups
who want to buy it in bulk so that they
can distribute it directly to the people
who need it the most it can be basically
impossible and look there are certain
things you would want to go out of your
way to discourage people from having in
their homes nazi flags pet chimps a tv
playing an episode of blue bloods but
narcan
is absolutely not one of them but
perhaps the biggest step that we could
make regarding harm reduction is to
properly support overdose prevention
centers sometimes called supervised
injection sites they're places where
people can bring their own drugs and
have access to clean supplies and
trained professionals who can intervene
in the event of an overdose as well as
direct them toward tons of other
services including addiction treatment
if they so choose here's a look inside
one of them right here in new york city
when we were inside there were half a
dozen clients using drugs no more
improperly discarded syringes on the
streets near our schools in our subway
stations you won't
the voice behind the divider belonged to
a man named oz who told us he's a marine
corps veteran and was using heroin as we
suppose
i've gotten more help here than i've
gotten from uh
you know from the va
wow that is incredible and i know that
we as a society have learned not to
trust anyone named oz who is either
yelling at you from behind a curtain or
trying to talk to you about something
medical but
we should make an exception here on both
counts because this particular oz makes
a very important point overdose
prevention centres provide crucial
services that keep people who use drugs
as safe as possible and yet whenever
they are floated as an option people
freak the [ __ ] out
it's actually a heroin shooting gallery
and that's really what it is it is a
community center for heroin addicts to
go and shoot up under supervision which
i think isn't is crazy the best way to
prevent overdoses from heroin is to have
people stop doing heroin they called it
harm reduction centers
but in my way of thinking it's really
harm enabling centers there's so many
other things to deal with than you know
letting people shoot up safely it's
it's just like condoning doing drugs
it's like why don't i go do it
okay but that's not at all what these
centers are for they're not for the
heroin curious to sample flights of
syringes like ipas
they're to help people who already use
drugs do so in a way that won't [ __ ]
kill them we know overdoses often happen
when people use drugs alone with no one
around to help them and these facilities
are designed to make sure that that
doesn't happen and politicians who
actually study these sites like the
former mayor of ithaca new york come
away impressed the first time i heard it
i thought it sounded like we were just
enabling people to use drugs
but the truth is in the places where
it's worked in australia and europe and
in canada
more people get off of drugs right
people use supervised injection are 30
percent more likely to enter into
treatment
and they're 100 less likely to die
just to underline that last point a
hundred percent no one has ever died
there in fact there has never been a
recorded death in any overdose
prevention center on earth that is
insane people die everywhere people die
at chuck e cheese
all the time by the way the ball pit
there is and this is true mostly bones
you want to know that rat's real name
it's charles execution cheese
and yet despite the fact that clip was
from six years ago ithaca still doesn't
have an overdose prevention center
because when cities float opening one
questions around their morality and even
legality make it next to impossible just
recently an opc in philadelphia was
prevented from opening after a
three-judge panel found it violated a
provision in federal law known as the
crack house statute which bans
facilities that operate for the purpose
of using illegal drugs yet another 1980s
law that we're still suffering from
which is just infuriating so often the
problem facing all harm reduction
programs is that people are so angry
with those who use drugs they want to
try and punish them into abstinence but
that is not how any of this works and
advocates have been trying to tell us
this for a long time like louise vincent
who points out that for decades we've
been going at this completely wrong
all we do is disconnect people in the
united states so if you are found to be
a person who uses drugs and needs help
we start with disconnecting you
and i truly believe that addiction is
the opposite of connection
so
what we do is everything wrong to help a
person we disconnect people from their
families we disconnect people from their
friends we alienate people from work we
disconnect them from community
and then we disconnect them from their
freedom finally and when people finally
have nothing left
then they will use until they die
right when people have nothing left they
will use until they die it is [ __ ]
dark it's horrible and right now you can
make a pretty good case that deliberate
or not it is the end goal of u.s public
health policy so given that
what do we do from here well for
starters the fda should remove
naloxone's prescription-only status and
they should do that right now and
crucially not just for expensive brand
name nasal sprays like narcan but for
low-cost generic naloxone which is 30
times cheaper as for state legislatures
they should re-examine their
paraphernalia laws to make sure that
people aren't held liable for holding
basic protective tools like drug testing
equipment and finally we need a
full-throated endorsement of overdose
prevention centers from the biden
administration because remember right
now as philly is finding out they are
arguably illegal thanks to that crack
house statute now the bible
administration could intervene here and
take a stand in their favor which is
frankly the very least that biden could
do because if you're wondering who is
the guy who authored the crack house
legislation i've got some bad news for
you
i'm the guy who authored the crack house
legislation
oh thanks for clarifying joe
nice larry king costume by the way and
look
this administration has done some real
good in being the first to broadly
endorse harm reduction tactics but
advocates say that much much more is
needed including making sure that people
who use drugs have a seat at the table
during policy discussions and the
funding gets to community-based
organizations providing the most
services for them but we all need to get
on board here our ingrained stigmas
around drugs and the people who use them
run really deep and if we actually want
to minimize deaths and keep people safe
the facts point in a very clear
direction we need to meet people where
they are help them transition into safe
drug use to stay alive and remove
barriers for those seeking addiction
treatment and what we absolutely need to
stop doing is spreading misinformation
and warehousing drug users in prisons or
to say all of that much more succinctly
it is well past time to start paying
attention to the man behind the curtain
you